[Música]
es momento de conocer Cuáles son las
principales noticias en materia
económica y por eso nos acompaña Juan
Pablo lucume y muy buenas noches Juan
Pablo nos vemos nuevamente Santiago así
es Es un gusto para mí bueno empezamos
porque hoy hablaron por teléfono dos
líderes muy importantes no acerca del
acuerdo entre el mercosur y la Unión
Europea estamos hablando del presidente
del gobierno español Pedro Sánchez y el
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
Silva en la conversación discutieron
sobre las negociaciones necesarias para
concluir en el acuerdo comercial y en
este caso particular es importante esta
llamada porque ambos ostentan la
presidencia Pro tempore en este segundo
semestre para el caso de Lula en
mercosur y Pedro Sánchez con la
presidencia del Consejo de la Unión
Europea el martes el presidente de
Uruguay Luis lacalle mostró su
preocupación por la falta de
flexibilidad del mercosur y dijo que si
no es posible trabajar de forma conjunta
Uruguay buscaría un acuerdo de forma
independiente leeremos ahora un apartado
del comunicado oficial el gobierno de
Brasil que dice lo siguiente y cito el
presidente Sánchez reiteró la invitación
al presidente del urá para participar en
la sesión inaugural de la Cumbre celac
Unión Europea en julio próximo en
Bruselas la Cumbre no se ha celebrado
desde 2015 y termina diciendo el
presidente Lula aceptó la invitación y
es que recordemos que Lula había puesto
en duda su asistencia a la Cumbre entre
la Unión Europea y la celac Pero ahora
con la intención de poder concluir el
acuerdo este mismo año el presidente
brasileño ha considerado que es el
momento perfecto para dar lo que llamó
como un impulso político al Tratado con
el mercosur sin embargo el comunicado de
plan alto no precisó lo discutido por
ambos mandatarios sobre las
negociaciones entre ambos bloques
comunitarios vamos ahora bien al norte
del continente americano a Canadá Juan
tenés información sobre las estrategias
y los esfuerzos que está haciendo el
gobierno en un estado de operación para
compensar la fuerte subida de los
precios que está sucediendo allí
Santiago Pues el Gobierno Federal empezó
a compartir ayudas económicas para cerca
de 11 millones de canadienses de bajos
ingresos los cheques gubernamentales van
entre los 176 y 472 dólares
estadounidenses y hacemos la conversión
desde la moneda local una cifra que
depende pues del número de hijos y los
ingresos obtenidos en 2021 de estas
familias Y es que si nos vamos a los
datos lo podemos revisar a continuación
la inflación en este país ha estado en
descenso pero pues aunque llegó al 3,4%
este dato anual de mayo viene desde el
8% vienen descenso pero en los precios
de los alimentos todavía vemos que está
muy elevado ronda al 9% y básicamente
por eso es esta ayuda muy interesante
este gráfico Juan Bueno vamos ahora a
Europa para hablar del presupuesto de la
primera Economía del continente para el
año 2024 estamos hablando de Alemania el
consejo de ministros de ese país aprobó
este miércoles el presupuesto que prevé
una reducción del gasto en términos
generales Aunque hace una pequeña
excepción en el sector de la defensa el
plan del gobierno prevé un gasto de
245.700 millones de euros lo que
representa un 6,4% menos de lo que se
prevé gastar este año el gasto en
defensa aumentará entonces en 1700
millones de euros hasta los 51.800
millones de euros Pero sigue quedándose
corto para lo que espera el Ministerio
de defensa germano y también lejos del
2% del pib que el país se ha
comprometido a gastar en este rubro un
compromiso que se hizo con la otan bajo
el contexto de la Guerra de Ucrania este
presupuesto definitivamente es un ajuste
de cinturón fuerte para la primera
economía europea así lo explicó el
ministro de finanzas
en resumen todavía estamos en un periodo
de altas tasas de inflación e incluso en
un entorno económico incierto pero en
nuestra costosa política fiscal Debe
llegar a su fin después de años de
crisis Este es un requisito no solo de
la Constitución sino también de la
sabiduría económica
bueno Juan qué nos dicen los indicadores
de la jornada vamos a verlos porque
evidentemente este anuncio por ejemplo
de Alemania afectó las bolsas en el
continente y Frankfurt cerró con una
pérdida del
0,63%, seguida de las pérdidas de
Londres y de París en América Latina
destacaron las ganancias de México y de
Brasil en medio de una jornada de
pérdidas dirigidas por Estados Unidos
lugares donde sus tres principales
indicadores también cerraron después del
día de la independencia del 4 de julio y
precisamente pasamos a los indicadores
de Wall Street Porque cerraron en rojo
un escenario causado principalmente
porque hoy se conocieron las minutas de
la reserva Federal en la que se
evidenció división entre sus miembros
Pues a pesar de la decisión unánime de
hacer una pausa en la subida de las
tasas de interés algunos dijeron que
hubieran preferido otro aumento en junio
en medio del mercado laboral ajustado y
cuál es hoy la cifra del día pues vamos
a mirar las imágenes porque son los 2000
metros cuadrados del Dreamhouse de
Barbie ubicado en Santa Mónica cerca de
Los Ángeles Estados Unidos un dato que
tra emos hoy Santiago Pues porque
estamos cerca del estreno de la película
de este juguete de Mattel que ha tenido
mucha acogida en redes sociales y que
estoy seguro ustedes ya está planillado
para ver la película pronto Así es la
estoy esperando ansiosamente Gracias
Juan por otra completísima Crónica nos
vemos mañana con mucho más